foreign
[Music]
and that memo has come via Pakistan
that global warming goals that we
thought of the timelines we thought of
are not going at the pace we thought
they would at the climate modeling is
off everything is off
as far as I can see there is an inland
sea hospitals schools medical centers
power grids everything has been taken
over by the great Deluge we've been
hearing stories from fathers who
couldn't bury their children because
there was no dry land we heard stories
about children who were drinking from
the same water with their dead cattle
was floated
[Music]
the size of the water is so huge that if
this water was there in Portugal whole
Portugal would be underwater whole
Ecuador would be underwater
the Colorado state of the U.S would be
underwater the UK would be underwater
entire UK no City no town without water
everybody would be drowning in this
water with six to eight feet of water
standing
[Music]
poorest people in Pakistan have been
planted even more
Pakistan will probably have sea life
expectancy go down Pakistan will
probably see infant mortality go up
Pakistan will probably see women dying
at childbirth you know that number go up
so a lot of really in terms of human
development index you in terms of human
misery I think it would be much worse
this climate change and Trauma sees no
borders my country one day tomorrow it's
another it is a big test case for
Humanity it is a wake-up call to all the
countries who've forgotten about
multilateralism about the rules of that
Global game and how Humanity has to
fight to just keep its feet on the
ground before the planet burns up
foreign
[Music]